this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base
a subscription website where you can
download thousands of medical
images and videos to use in lectures
courses
presentations professional training and
more for more information
click on the link in the description
transurethral resection of the prostate
or terp is a surgical procedure during
which part of the prostate gland is
removed
the prostate is a walnut-sized gland in
men that is located at the base of the
bladder where it wraps around the
urethra
a terp is often performed for a
condition called benign prostatic
hyperplasia
in this non-cancerous condition the
prostate enlarges to the point of
causing difficulty with urination
a terp may also be performed in patients
with prostate cancer
to relieve bladder obstruction
when you arrive at the hospital for your
surgery an intravenous line will be
started you may be given antibiotics to
decrease your chance of infection
a terp may be performed under general or
spinal anesthesia
if you're given general anesthesia you
will be unconscious and a breathing tube
will be inserted into your throat to
help you breathe for the duration of the
operation
if you receive spinal anesthesia you
will remain conscious
and the lower half of your body will be
numb during the operation
you'll be given sedation to help you
relax an
uncomplicated terp usually takes about
an hour to perform
your surgeon will begin by slipping a
small lighted instrument called a
cystoscope through the opening of your
penis
after instilling sterile solution
through the cystoscope for better
visibility
your surgeon will carefully examine the
inside of your urethra
prostate and bladder he or she will then
pass a receptoscope
which essentially consists of a small
wire loop carrying an electric current
through the cystoscope and use it to
shape off layers of prostate tissue
these bits will be washed into the
bladder and out through a special port
in the cystoscope
when an optimal amount of prostate
tissue has been excised
your surgeon will remove the cystoscope
and place a catheter into your bladder
to keep it draining for up to two days
after the surgery
following the procedure you will be
taken to the recovery area for
monitoring and given pain medication as
needed
you may continue to receive antibiotics
through your intravenous line
and a sterile solution may be flushed
intermittently through the catheter tube
to wash out accumulated blood and clots
most patients are released from the
hospital within two days of the
procedure